Well,
hello, how are you? I greet you, Andrés González,
with his brief information for today, Thursday
, February 25. The Metropolitan Police
say that a man beat his neighbor
to death and they do not know why this
happened at 8 p.m. yesterday in a
nearby apartment complex.  from
sahara and slow for some reason while
arguing with his girlfriend
the subject went upstairs and
brutally attacked his neighbor until he was
killed
some students from preschool
to third grade will return to classes on
monday here in clark county
however the district plans  the return of
all students conducting a
hybrid learning model on
March 22 students in
grades 6 9 and 2 will return and on
April 6 2 of 7 8 10 and 11 the district
will continue to offer
full-time distance learning  for
those families who feel more
comfortable using this method
and by reducing the positive cases of
coronavirus or nevada leaders
states are allowing the public in
several places however the
health district says that there will be inspectors
controlling the public places
where people return to events this
rule will be modified if the
number of infections increases
and now we move on to the weather forecast
we will have some winds  in the
valley all day with a sunny sky
reaching 61 degrees for tomorrow
we will see higher temperatures
however the wind will return for
this weekend have a nice
day I am andrés gonzález and this was
about the news now news in
Spanish
[Music]